I was just talking to Vigo and he told
me that before you started filming you
told the entire crew that if you've got
any ideas come to me so I was wondering
did anybody out there really come to you
with an idea that we could see on screen
no they were afraid of me so no yes they
did I always do that actually when I
start a movie and I say you know if
anybody and it started from the
beginning Dumb and Dumber my brother and
I had never done any movies before and
we had never done a commercial and done
a video and done anything so I knew the
whole crew knew more than we knew about
production so I said ever anybody see
something we're doing wrong or an angle
we're not getting please come forward
and they would but this one was more
important because this was about race
and we had a very diverse crew and I
just want to make sure that we weren't
missing something that some white guy
isn't going to see about a black person
and you know did people did come forward
and they would say I don't know if he'd
say this or if you say that or if you do
that and you know sometimes they were
right or some types of well he actually
didn't know we have the thing but it was
making you know keeping it in check and
making sure that we were doing trying to
do everything right so refreshing to
hear that approach well you don't hear
it very often well I I'm not like a you
went on as a movie set I believe like it
is a team effort you know and by the way
all not all forms of art maybe painting
isn't but a books are too you know you
read a book you know if I you know
Norman Mailer and you think wow he came
up with that well you know he has an
editor he's got friends going through
the book he's got all all these things
people are helping and I take as much
help as I can get because I know I I
don't know I'm not that smart and I
can't I don't know everything
no I I had a thick skin I was an
accounting major undergrad so when I get
to grad school for creative writing I
was a miracle I got in first of all I
did realize recognize that I'm behind
everybody else they know more than me
they've studied more than me and so I
had a very thick skin and I could take
criticism and that was one of my
strengths like I get beat up hand in a
short story and there to say this stinks
because of this this this and this I'm
writing down nothing okay
and I could take it where other people
they get their feelings hurt and they
didn't hand in stuff that unless they
felt it was perfect and then it was like
what's the point you know my whole point
was like beat me up show me what I'm
doing wrong here
well speaking of that here you have a
really delicate balance I think between
the drama and the comedy is that
something that you know that it feels
right while you're making it or do you
have to resort to screen testing it no
you I think I'm right but I'm not always
right like there are things throughout
all my movies where I think this is
correct but then you do test and you
find out it's not correct and now I'll
give you an example like in my first
movie something about me I mean Dumb and
Dumber
there's the snowball scene where Jeff
Daniels picks up a snowball Wings and
hits Lauren Holly in the face and the
place explodes you know we're doing test
screening and everybody laughs you know
very funny but when originally we had it
she looks up and she's got a bloody nose
and wound no more laughs everybody stops
you're like now it's not funny she's
bleeding she's heard and we had to get
rid of it you know CGI it out and then
then the next test screen she comes up
and she's just got a face full of snow
and the laughter goes for another you
know 15 seconds so you you learned but
this one did feel I did have a sense of
what we were doing and you know what was
going to work what was it mm-hmm to wrap
up now we do a show a Collider called
Collider fyc where we get to celebrate
all the movies that we're going to be
talking about through award season and
something that we're always discussing
in you know constructively arguing about
is the idea of the term Oscar movie what
exactly it means to you personally so I
wanted to pose that question to you what
does an Oscar movie mean to you um I you
know this is the first time I've been in
that loop and so I'm honored that
they're even talking about the movie in
regard you know would you know there's
Oscar talk but what it means to me is
that people are gonna hear about the
movie and that's what's important to me
I want people to see this movie I really
do
I'd run much rather getting zero Oscars
and make a ton of it like everybody goes
and sees it it's not make money it's get
people to eyeballs on it it's not about
the thing I would just want people to
see because I do believe
we can make a little difference you know
people can it could bring people
together it's about people on both sides
of the aisle and how they gradually
knock down the walls and become friends
and I think it's relevant today and
that's why I want people to see it
[Music]